hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play The Crooked
Man okay a lot of people have been
asking me to play this one and I know
I've been lacks on my playthroughs you
guys have just been itching for more
content so I finally after working for
about 10 hours straight if you were
following those eeeh manly amn today and
that was super fun thank you guys so
much for your questions and if I didn't
get to you I apologize we were trying so
hard to get everyone done we recorded
many videos and stuff but just not
enough time so anyway I finally managed
to get a block of time to start another
playthrough and we are gonna do the
Crooked Man because it is gone too big
right that was a pretty creepy picture
of The Crooked Man in the beginning this
game contains sudden surprises oh boy
and harsh images oh boy the weakened
part and those poor with Horrors should
not play yes me the author takes no
responsibility for any trouble that
arises from playing this game okay a lot
of people have been saying that I need
to play this game I needa there was a
crooked man and he walked a crooked mile
how adorable he found a crooked sixpence
upon a crooked stile nice little mercy
run he bought a crooked cat which caught
a crooked Mouse and they all lived in a
crooked house and they all live together
in a little crooked house everyone knows
that Nursery Rhymes are actually really
horrible songs if you listen to the
lyrics are pretty awful whoo finally
things look tidy in here that should be
that is there anything else we can help
you with David no I'm fine sorry for
making you guys help me move on thanks
for showing me the place ball I'll have
to pay you back sometime
ooh nice the three of us could go out
drinking I look forward to it already
well we'd better get going got it be
careful you too
oh how nice even the music is nice now
this is another RPG horror maker if you
couldn't tell and it's gonna wait oh
whoops
oh wait that was Paul's license sorry I
was accidentally pressed space too
quickly sorry guys are you always that
quick off the gun okay there's a large
crack in the wall there I'm just quickly
glancing over everything to see if
there's anything else important that I
need I'm right in bed
no time for that let's keep going there
you lazy bastard okay old computer
closet to hide in empty trash can
nothing in there I'm guessing I need to
go give Paul his license back washbasin
don't want to go or you don't need to go
I'm scared to go to the bathroom little
Billy huh you hear someone I heard
someone ah who do you hear buddy what
what was that you can't just do that to
me what was that what's with that place
seriously it's filthy it's practically
falling apart what were you thinking you
wanted to move for a change of pace and
that will not help him you hear oh
that's them talking I thought that was a
lake a little chipmunk demon look what
can I do he's not the richest guy you
know can't even afford much furniture
besides you told me to look for the
place right don't come complaining to me
now you're right I'm sorry
one of those is a woman one of the
forces I'm doing is a woman's voice I
just wanted to help David I know look I
should be sorry we'll visit some other
time well talking gets distance what a
bunch of douche tastic friends you are
the license can wait I guess better get
to bed well if you say so hanging oops
hang on whoa whoa phone whoa hey oh hey
ho hey ho ha hello hello who is this who
was found shirley is that you my love
Shirley what oh all right then
well I guess they hung up I'll just call
it a day I should take it easy for my
first day in the new place you're not
gonna talk about how your douche tastic
friends sold you to place it was falling
apart and most likely haunted by giant
demons that are crooked man I'm tired
wonder what things gonna happen in the
night
uh-uh really is as it when crying I
can't sleep through this I hear
something right outside my door it might
be one of my neighbors who's very angry
at me okay so oh I'm playing now okay
never mind I thought I was just sitting
there for something to happen
okay so someone is crying oh hello
oh it's one of my neighbors oh okay I'm
actually 206 looks at empty hello I'm
just what was that what was that I heard
something okay yes who is it it's a
shower pardon me it's just I can hear
you from my room even me it's making it
hard to sleep would you stop huh
what are you saying I was asleep until
you woke me you're trying to start
something you're trying to start
something funny Jim you're the guy who
moved into 205 right there's no way
you'd hear me from there what how do you
know where I'm from or I guess so wait
sorry for waking you goodbye now she's
right the rooms are pretty far apart
more importantly it was a man's voice
was it just my imagination why did you
bother an old lady whatever I better get
back to sleep well hang on let me okay
nothing to do on the first floor alright
never mind then I guess we're going back
now oh what's going on stop yikes the
water is the faucet busted or it is so
[Music]
under the bed what's under the bed under
the bed is ball try to break what's
under the bed
what's under the bed what's under the
bed
it's another madman what's under the bed
under the bed huh what's down here what
got a scrap oh I thought I was gonna see
something down there okay you scared me
for nothing ever since she okay
ever since she went away I spent every
night clutching my sweaty pillow
writhing I can't say goodbye week here
what other choice do I have
what's this did the former tenant leave
this or did the crooked man leave it oh
whatever
I'll get to bed if you say so David if
that is your real name
okay I'm swearing I swear I think I'm
hearing something like right outside my
door it's not cool man that sounds still
where's it coming from give me a break I
need to sleep oh okay then I guess it's
morning now hello who is it
hello that weird sound oh yeah thanks
for all the no no I didn't mean just I'm
busy with work so yeah so come visit
today tell her that for me okay bye is
that your ex who left you man I slept in
two noon
I'd better go so much for taking it easy
what do you mean sleeping in to noon
seems like the easiest thing you could
possibly do oh hi my friend Paul what is
it yeah oh I forgot my license yesterday
was it on the table oh yeah there sorry
I was gonna bring it to you but whew
Thanks so you going somewhere yeah to
the hospital and I see take care of
yourself buddy yeah [ __ ] you too pal I
know what you saw me this crappy
apartment oh yeah Paul did you write
something on the bathroom mirror huh
right on the mirror what kind of child
is brat
you take me for David getting a little
defensive aren't you Paul
sorry I didn't mean it like that anyway
I'm off or if you say so what the where
oh I'm at a hospital okay I guess no
needs what the hell was that it's weird
this game has like random interjected
voices like disembodied and strange mom
it's been a while are you doing okay No
oh my if it isn't little Tommy Timmy
you've certainly grown no my name is
David good you look healthy sorry I
can't see you very much I've been busy
with work but I took a few days off so I
moved into this great room with
furniture and everything where were you
before it's near your favorite cake shop
too so when you get better we can live
there together
my that's wonderful get along with Linda
will you all that fighting you two
worries me maybe you could come I can
come visit this time you like our Popeye
don't you I make the best I know how
mom I'm not Timmy I'm your son David
remember oh yes they opened a bakery the
other day it smells so wonderful maybe I
should buy from there
mom oh hopefully like she seems to have
some sort of Alzheimer's Oh who would
you be why are you here yeah she seems
to have some sort of Alzheimer's how did
you get in this is my room you have the
wrong room who are you say something
will you mom
Oh get out I'll have you thrown out okay
somebody somebody there's a strange man
in my room get rid of him now
damn it mrs. Hoover mrs. Hoover don't
strain yourself please go to sleep okay
who are you don't touch me get away this
is actually really really sad no calm
down this let's get you into bed I mean
I'm sorry David leave your mother to us
you'll have to leave for today it's
really a damn shame Alzheimer's we've
done at Alzheimer's charity before and
it's just sometimes really sad to see
people forget their entire family Davey
is that my Davey Boy where are you going
why are you leaving me mom your flight
school advantag zamzar coming up well
you want to be a pilot don't you your
mother always has your back please don't
leave me alone I don't want to be alone
here Davey please oh man mom it's me
remember mom that's really sad
David please leave she's very confused
right now but she said my I said leave
that's not good
hello doctor tell me something sad and
depressing
hello David did you see your mother yeah
though I guess she still doesn't know me
yes you've forgotten many things and
she's having trouble controlling your
emotions I asked you to be patient she
may well get better so yeah I can you
can live with her again Thanks
I hope you can help her really I mean I
have to say that this game has a really
good story so far I'm really into it I
know oh man I swear to God I don't know
what's in the game ruin this sounds god
my wire just fell down on my leg oh my
god Oh what is that what is where did
this come from
Oh okay I don't know what's happening
here but something happened something
moved I don't know what what happened I
heard something move I don't even know
what's happening right now wait did
someone move that chair was that chair
always to the right did I move that
chair Oh No oh there's something in the
drawer Oh got a leaflet for school looks
pretty old mmm these LLM courses are
circled when somebody's shooting to be a
lawyer I guess this must be the former
tenants you sure for God a bunch of
stuff maybe no furniture is better after
all huh all right
oh damn it you always catch me just as
I'm about to say god damn hello hello
hey David how are you doing who are
Marion oh you saw me just yesterday yeah
I'm doing fine thanks good good call if
you ever lonely okay by the way I got a
call from Shirley yesterday we didn't
really talk but sorry I told her your
number she said she was worried about
you
it's okay tell her I don't need to worry
or her worry she should just look out
for herself all right well I'll hang up
now
a clang okay dot dot dot well this is
awfully interesting hmm I'm tired of
reading I should go to bed if you say so
but what nightmares waits you in the
darkness more crying I'm guessing
okay was why did it turn on by itself it
is broken
ah no whoo hey all right
wha-what is this is creepy right they
did say sink what was that I don't know
let's check the sink it's a bit there's
a scrap of paper under here somehow got
a scrap the paper there was a crooked
man there was a crooked man and he
walked a crooked mile he found a crooked
sixpence against a crooked style he
bought a crooked cat which caught a
crooked Mouse and they all lived
together in a little crooked house yeah
there's a mother Goose rhyme coz it's
it's getting [ __ ] you
okay I'm someone is [ __ ] with me
someone's got to be why is it is here
under this sink
I guess the previous tenant this is so
strange I should sleep and forget about
it
you're damn right okay Oh sink well here
we go
moving for a change of pace huh guess
that's not working so well I appreciate
Paul and Marian's help but even though
they're giant dicks is that a kid I hear
what kid would live in these beat-up
apartments hey maybe there's lost I
should know no no don't do that don't
don't do that don't do that
you don't want to do that I don't want
to do that to do that I don't want to do
that alright okay I'm not in control of
course there's no kids here must be
getting tired
[Music]
Oh cup fell over geez that startled me
weight would help me written in doo doo
oh the coffee it's written in coffee you
gotta be this room is really really
strange with its voices in TVs turning
on yeah what is this this would be the
point where I would run out of this
place as hazards but I would not sleep
in this place are you joking me oh my
god
what was yeah what's up man you sound
sleepy huh huh yeah oh he wasn't even
sleeping I gotta ask you something is
now okay yeah what do you know who used
to live in this room
was it a crooked man with a crooked
smile you asked the landlady he curious
about something
well seems like he forgot a lot of stuff
but I said landlady sure later LAN lays
on the far end of the first floor I'll
go see what she won oh if you say so man
oh man I'm really liking this one I mean
these RPG hordes are always very story
driven I'm really liking how this one is
going so anyway thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye